I'm Kennedy I'm Bill hemmer I'm Harris
Faulkner and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Friday sept
2020
Rosenthal the president of China left
his country for the first time since the
early days of the pandemic and attended
a meeting with Russia's president a
summit Iran was at as well the world
that respects human dignity the rest of
the world that
prepared to trade on a fair and
reciprocal basis the rest of the world
is United that's some 70 75 percent of
the global economy is on the side of
Freedom we should reinforce that we
speak with former Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo I'm Chris Foster anything
can happen and the polls are tightening
in some races but previous predictions
of a republican Red Wave in November are
a little less loud now are Democrats now
going to peek at the right moment it's
always historically a tough year that
first midterm for president in office
but the wind seemed to be shifting and
helping the Democrats right now we speak
with Fox News host and chief legal
correspondent Shannon Breen and I'm
Janice Dean I've got the final word on
the Fox News Rundown
[Music]
the presidents of China and Russia met
up this week at the Shanghai cooperation
organization at a summit in Uzbekistan
while there China's Xi Jinping held a
bilateral meeting with Russia's Vladimir
Putin after which she said through a
translator China is willing to make
efforts with Russia to assume the role
of great powers in the face of changes
in the world times and history China is
willing to work with Russia to
demonstrate the responsibility of a
major country play a leading role and
inject stability into a turbulent World
Putin praised China for taking what he
called a balanced position on the
Ukrainian crisis and said of the U.S
attempts to create a unipolar world have
acquired an ugly form he defended
China's stance over Taiwan as also heard
here through a translator for our part
we stand firm on the One China principle
we condemn provocations of the U.S and
its satellites in the Taiwan Strait
before Russia invaded Ukraine the two
leaders announced a friendship Without
Limits Texas Republican senator John
Corden told Fox News Thursday to prove
the adage that the enemy of my enemy is
my friend and this is a marriage of
convenience between the People's
Republic of China and Russia but they're
both autocrats there was another country
at the Shanghai cooperation organization
meeting Iran and U.S Secretary of State
Anthony blinken said just this week
negotiations on a new joint
comprehensive plan of action or jcpoa
addressing Iran's nuclear program are
failing Iran seems either unwilling or
unable to do what is necessary to reach
an agreement and they continue to try to
introduce extraneous issues
to uh to the negotiation that make an
agreement
um uh less likely but certainly what
we've seen in the last week is a step
backward away from the uh likelihood of
any kind of near-term agreement and at
the same time Iran signed a memorandum
of obligation to join the Shanghai
organization with China and Russia so
this Administration has made concessions
of extraordinary proportions in an
effort to get that deal done they were
prepared to give a trillion dollars to
the Iranians and the deal itself would
have permitted the Iranians to
eventually develop a nuclear program
Mike Pompeo is the former Secretary of
State and former head of the CIA when I
hear secretary blinken say that he
doesn't think it's likely it's going to
happen it reminds me how bad an idea it
would have been to take that deal
clearly the Iranians had no intention of
complying with it if they had and now
have made clear to us their intention to
build out their nuclear weapons program
it means this Administration must get
it's serious at reimposing and
continuing to enforce all of the
sanctions we had in place and preparing
to do all that it takes to make sure
that the Islamic Republic of Iran that
regime there never has the capability to
conduct a nuclear test or to build out a
nuclear weapons program there have been
multiple reports as you know that one of
the bigger holdups in this was their
refusal to allow the iaea to further
investigate some Trace uranium particles
found at some of these Undeclared sites
this summer after President Biden went
to the Middle East Iranian officials
announced that they did in fact now have
the technical capability to build a
nuclear weapon but had not yet decided
if they would do so
you kind of referenced it but what do we
do now with this information there are
sanctions in place already right so what
should be next
so three ideas first there are sanctions
but we have not enforced them these last
two years the Chinese Communist party is
purchasing crude oil for cash other
countries have begun to be able to
provide wealth to the Iranians even
while the sanctions remain sanctions are
worthless if not enforced so step one
Global massive enforcement just as we
had a maximum pressure campaign for two
and a half years of the Trump
Administration that's the path it will
starve the Beast and at the very least
reduce the capacity to conduct missile
tests Terror around the world
and make it harder for them to spend
their centrifuges which are key to
developing their nuclear weapons program
second we need to make clear to them the
enormous costs if they begin to proceed
down a path to a nuclear weapon we I'm
happy if we want to do that privately
but we should make very clear to them
that this regime cannot possibly survive
with a nuclear weapon finally we have to
make sure we get all of that right in
the context of the Abraham Accords and
my understanding of the Middle East
which is that if we don't do one and two
that I just laid out it won't just be
around with a nuclear weapon the Kingdom
of Saudi Arabia the United Arab Emirates
other nations will feel compelled to
begin to develop their capabilities so
that they can protect themselves from
Iran and our friend Israel our security
partner in the region Israel the right
full homeland of the Jewish people
Israel I promise you we need to stand
next to Israel making clear that our two
Nations will not tolerate a nuclear
weapon and if we do those things I'm
convinced we can change the calculus for
the Ayatollah and for president raisi
and forced them down a path which never
gives them any incentive to continue
their nuclear weapons work
your thoughts on the Shanghai
cooperation organization this week Iran
signed a memorandum to join Xi Jinping
said China and Russia will work together
as great Powers after this meeting with
Putin British intelligence said it
appeared Russia has put Iranian drones
to use Russia's deepening ties with
North Korea you see all of this what is
happening as these adversaries get
closer and what should our response be
do we deepen our ties with our allies is
that our response
fascinating question because if you
think about it you have just identified
every friend of the Chinese Communist
Party there's just a handful just the
Iranians just the Venezuelans just the
Cubans just the North Koreans and now
Vladimir Putin himself
the rest of the world the world that
respects human dignity the rest of the
world that is prepared to trade on a
fair and reciprocal basis the rest of
the world is United that's some 70 75
percent of the global economy is on the
side of Freedom we should reinforce that
and if the Iranians want to pick the
Communist side if they want to side with
the Chinese Communist Party the Chinese
Communist Party should suffer from that
as well and instead this Administration
has allowed China and Iran and Russia to
trade freely to engage in activities
that we don't allow anyone else to
that's creating wealth for the bad guys
and we we can stop this we can use the
might of the Free World to impose real
cost on Nations who choose to behave in
such a malign way the fact that we were
negotiating with the Iranians through
the Russians while the Iranians were
selling the Russians technology Hardware
drones that was killing ukrainians
Ukrainian civilians suggest that this
Administration doesn't have the right
end of the stick they don't understand
that we are an exceptional nation and we
should defend our value set everywhere
and always
one of the biggest responses to U.S
sanctions over the years it appears is
countries like Iran and China and Russia
saying okay we're just not going to deal
in U.S dollars anymore we're going to
operate and accept each other's
currencies I'm aware I'm oversimplifying
this and the US dollar is still the
preferred Reserve currency but it is
declining and Saudi Arabia this year
said they were considering using China's
currency to trade oil with China
what if the security implications as
countries adversaries even maybe allies
move away from the dollar
played correctly by the United States
and our Ally Nations the likelihood of
that happening is exceedingly low it is
true that sanctions create risk we
didn't make the Europeans happy they
wanted the jcpoa we wanted freedom and
so they threatened to go around the U.S
system and Swift in fact they couldn't
we were told that American sanctions
alone wouldn't work we took the Iranian
economy to the lowest levels it had ever
been in and when the by Administration
came in the Iranian economy will grow
faster in 2022 than the American economy
we can protect and preserve the dollar
as the reserve currency because it is
the one place that every nation in the
world knows you can trade with America
in American dollars and you will be
repaid and this is a stable good country
they know that if they do a deal with
the Russians or the Chinese that it is
the Chinese political system not the
Chinese commercial system they'll be
addressing we should protect the dollar
we can do so in a smart way the
sanctions regime will not be the thing
that undermines America as the reserve
currency and while you correctly point
out that there are more countries
prepared to conduct International
Commerce outside of the dollar
environment that number is still tiny
and fractional and insignificant today
I want to ask you about Russia some
politicians and council members even a
former member of Russia's Parliament
have started questioning Vladimir Putin
publicly over the war in Ukraine St
Petersburg counselor I was reading even
called for Putin to resign
I understand in Russia that's you don't
do that when you combine that with
Ukraine's counter-offensive wins as of
late
what will happen does does Putin respond
by simply getting angrier and going
harder
my sense of this since the beginning has
been that those who fear provoking
Vladimir Putin misunderstand him
as as my as my grandfather would have
said he's done been provoked and you can
and you can prove it right you can prove
it with the tens of thousands of lives
that have been lost in just a matter of
months
this is a man who is intent upon his
mission and the only thing that will
stop him is changing his perception of
risk and so whether it's the Ukrainian
advances or the political actors who are
now beginning to say you know he may
have let us down a really dangerous path
for the Russian people we need to
continue we need to reinforce we need to
continue to urge Europe whose battle
this is in the first instance to be
serious about its own security and when
we get that right
we will decrease the probability that
Putin will continue this butcherous
campaign I I get asked often you didn't
ask this question quite but I get asked
Mike would this have happened if you
were still a secretary of state if
president Trump was still the president
and I can't answer that because it's a
counter factual but what I can say is it
didn't happen on our watch for four
years Vladimir Putin didn't invade
Europe he invaded it on President
Obama's watch he invaded it on President
Biden's watch what changed
well it wasn't Vladimir Putin to change
it was his perception of risk and so the
singular Focus for Europe and for the
West needs to be to change the risk
calculus as perceived by Vladimir Putin
and so to think we're going to have an
off ramp or a negotiated solution uh is
folly it misunderstands the evil of
Vladimir Putin and it misunderstands the
risk to Ukraine to Moldova to the Baltic
States to Europe and indeed the people
here at home who can see that this war
has cost the United States dearly
already
on China and Taiwan I want your sense of
a timeline we've had quite a few U.S
leaders go to Taiwan lately China
obviously doesn't like that we've seen
their reaction militarily are you
convinced China is about to do something
and what is your sense of when
I'm headed I was in Taiwan a few months
ago I'm headed back there myself before
too long
timelines are really the hardest
question to answer who would have
guessed that the Berlin Wall would have
come down when it did the answer is no
one uh what what one does is one does
the things they can do
to prepare to prevent our adversaries
from acting it's the model of straight
peace through strength it's the model
President Reagan had and the one that we
executed with respect to Taiwan uh we
should do the same we should be
acknowledging Taiwan as an independent
nation and we should be preparing them
and providing them the intelligence and
tools they need to protect their own
sovereignty building out alliances with
India with South Korea with Japan with
Australia with nations in the region who
are prepared to provide support to
Taiwan
and then demarcating for Xi Jinping the
actual cost that we will post on him if
he heads down his timeline his
timeline's pretty clear he's going to
have an election or what stands for an
election in October where he will be
declared leader for Life inside of the
Chinese Communist party and he has said
in the next handful of years he wants to
quote reunite end of quote Taiwan we
should never admit that there's such a
thing as reunification Taiwan has never
been part of China and we should work
fast now today to prevent Xi Jinping
from doing to Taiwan precisely what
Vladimir Putin did to Ukraine he got one
free bite at the Apple before NATO
responded we should make sure that Xi
Jinping knows he will not get one free
bite on Taiwan
one more if I may I know you have to go
on the home front your thoughts on the
FBI and doj search of Mar-A-Lago we hear
claims obviously have classified
information being stored there in the
context of you being former head of CIA
are the claims or reports troubling to
you or are you waiting to see and learn
more
oh goodness no uh rating a former
president's home someone who could be
your future political opponent is an
action that has never happened before
and presents has enormous implications
for America's Republic
if there's classified documents there
they shouldn't have been there they
weren't authorized to be there no former
Secretary of State no former secretary
offense indeed no former president
should retain classified information in
a place it is not authorized to be our
soldiers our Sailors our Airmen our
Marines all depend on the protection of
classified information and I get it
sometimes you open a classified document
and you say oh my goodness why was this
classified I get it if it's classified
it needs to be protected if it's it
shouldn't be classified it ought to be
Declassified and so it is possible for
both things to be true it is possible
that there are documents down there that
shouldn't have been if so they need to
be returned it is also the case that the
FBI and the justice department not
continuing to engage to make sure that
they got those documents back to their
rightful place if in fact there are
documents down there improperly by
conducting a rate of the home of a
former president is both unprecedented
and dangerous for our Republic
former Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
thank you so much for your time
it's great to be with you thank you have
a great day
[Music]
[Music]
this is Janice Dean with your Fox News
commentary coming up
Texas governor Greg Abbott has been
sending migrants North to New York
Chicago and Washington D.C telling us
here on the Fox News rundown last month
he's trying to alleviate the strain on
Border towns I'm helping the local
communities by bussing the the migrants
out of these local communities and
sending them up to the Northeast where
they have self-identified as sanctuary
cities where they want to welcome in any
illegal immigrant and I'm more than
happy to accommodate them some of those
migrants were dropped off in front of
Vice President Kamala Harris's official
residence in Washington after she said
on NBC's Meet the Press the border is
secure Carla bastillos rushed to meet
those migrants with the volunteer group
Sanctuary DMV this is very sad because
we're making a humanitarian crisis we're
making it political and a lot of time
and resources are being spent and
alleviating the chaos that the politics
of it is creating some of the migrants
sent to Chicago were then sent onto the
suburbs Burr Ridge Illinois Mayor Gary
Grasso says he got no heads up they are
not the problem they are they are
behaved there's no issue with them at
all
they're looking for school opportunities
we're inquiring as to whether or not
they can be employed by our local
businesses if that's an option we don't
even know frankly how long they're going
to stay Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
has sent two chartered Planes full of
migrants from his state to Martha's
Vineyard in Massachusetts Massachusetts
state representative Dylan Fernandez
says they got no heads up the planes
were coming these families then walked
several miles to Martha's Vineyard
Community Services because there's no
one there alerted to pick them up at
Community Services we brought them to
the high school as a staging area and
then ultimately to a shelter in Edgar
town where they are now in New York City
thousands of migrants still there at
least for now are in the shelter system
or put up in hotels every
sing differently to this but here in D.C
the mayor has declared a national excuse
me a local public emergency a health
emergency because of the folks who have
showed up here in DC and saying the
systems will be overwhelmed Shannon
bream's the host of Fox News Sunday and
you know there is the ongoing
conversation like these are human beings
these are people with children they are
dragged you know along and it's hard to
look at them and not have compassion and
think you know these are people caught
up in the middle of this conversation
that has turned exceptionally political
but cities where that are away from the
border that are now getting the influx
of these immigrants are quickly
realizing how much of a strain it puts
on their system and many of these areas
though have declared self-declared
themselves to be Sanctuary cities or
states and so they probably haven't felt
the brunt of what you know Texas Arizona
those folks right at the border are
going to feel so the folks who are
sending them North and when they land
there in the local officials declare an
emergency and say this is overwhelming
and unacceptable say well that's what's
happening to our little border towns
every day so so it seems like the two
sides are just going to talk past each
other it is going to remain political
for now but these are real people caught
in the middle
President Biden still gets poor marks as
far as polling goes on immigration but
overall his numbers have improved about
to where they were at the beginning of
this year and not were they cratered to
this summer and uh and then looking at
some midterm races a lot of those polls
are tightening up
um I wonder if this is this just goes to
show that people like us maybe pay
attention to this stuff a little bit too
early
yeah I think that polls always get
tighter the closer you get to an
election so you gotta take everything
with a grain of salt and Republicans
um you know they even earlier in the
year when they had these major margins
and I would talk to top leaders and they
would say we're nervous because we know
that this can change and they knew
different issues would come up and you
know a month or two in politics is a
lifetime and can make a huge difference
so there is good momentum for the
Democrats right now and for the
president listen the numbers are still
terrible I mean he's way upside down on
every single issue on his job
performance but they're moving in the
right direction and that asks the
question are Democrats now going to Peak
at the right moment it's always
historically a tough year that first
midterm for president in office but the
wind seemed to be shifting and helping
the Democrats right now although I
thought it was interesting the New York
Times ran a piece earlier this week
saying you know our Democrats going to
get smacked in the face and surprised by
polls almost felt like a little bit of
managing expectations so
um there's only so much we can know and
those polls Capture One Moment In Time
It's a moving Target in enthusiasm
getting people to show up and turn out
is going to make all the difference for
either side one of those polls that's
that seems to be tightening is that this
Pennsylvania Senate raised John Federman
and Mehmet Oz seems to be bridging a
little bit of that Gap now they've
agreed to a debate
on October 5th uh fetterman's been
recovering from the stroke he had in May
and Oz has been accusing him of you know
laying too low while he's been
crisscrossing the state now they're
going to have closed captioning for
fetterman's behalf he's having some what
he calls them auditory processing
problems
um some Republicans are saying that
fetterman stroke makes him you know a
bad candidate even worse but I wonder if
there's a chance unless he's proved to
be you know completely just mentally
incompetent somehow for this to pick up
sympathy votes a lot of people have
health problems a lot of people have
loved ones with health problems yeah
absolutely I think that's the risk that
the Republicans run in that Pennsylvania
race and it's so tricky because the
Republican candidate is a doctor he
knows way more about this than most of
us do then he's gonna have to find that
perfect line there of saying hey I have
concerns that this person could actually
physically handle the rigors of
representing Pennsylvania in the U.S
Senate versus coming off as somebody who
seems heartless and is in any way
potentially in sensitive to what's going
on with the fetterman recovery listen if
you're a political junkie it doesn't
matter if you live in Pennsylvania or
not you're going to find a way to watch
this debate because it's going to be
unlike anything else we've ever seen
it's going to get a ton of eyeballs and
as so many states have early voting and
people already making up their minds
these debates and pushing them back
further and some candidates are saying
no debates all together they really
could be difference makers in these
really tight races yeah you're right I
bet a lot of people who wouldn't
necessarily watch a Pennsylvania Senate
debate who do follow the news and follow
politics we'll find a way to to watch
that one I'm told that you're
interviewing South Carolina Republican
senator Lindsey Graham on Fox News
Sunday this week now some Republicans
are mad at him
for proposing this National 15-week
Abortion ban uh that some people are
calling a gift to Democrats now does it
but does it also tell abortion opponents
look come out and vote for us because
we're going to do this for you
I mean it is I have so many questions
yes he is exclusively with us on Fox
News Sunday this week because
Republicans have repeatedly said this is
an issue that should go back to the
States we have to overturn Roe that's
what the Supreme Court did now states
have a patchwork they're doing all kinds
of things from no access to abortion to
unfettered access to abortion
um and that's what Republicans have said
that they want it for the states to be
these Laboratories now Senator Graham is
coming out and he's always pushed a
20-week federal ban this is now 15 weeks
and he's saying it's never a bad time to
be out there defending The Unborn if
you're pro-life but you've got to think
political strategy because it seems like
Republicans some of them were even kind
of caught off guard that he would do
something when this that particular
topic is not a good one at least in the
polling for Republicans right now so
there is consternation inside the party
about this
um and some folks have publicly aired
their frustration that he would do this
this close to the midterm so yeah I got
a lot of questions I'm sure he'll have
answers I'm sure he will um yeah and
some Republican candidates like you said
who who are pro-life and and had it
almost prominently featured in their
campaign materials and their websites
have now kind of scrubbed it and said
yeah let's maybe let's maybe talk about
something else let's talk about the
economy right that's what the Republican
candidates want to talk about for sure
um so there's a deal to not have uh a
freight rail strike that could have
caused a lot of havoc in the economy um
I can't imagine a more Joe Biden cause
trains and you and you and unions
for him to be excited about he loves
trains he loves unions this could have
been a real problem for him politically
not to mention what it could have done
to the economy yes and at a time that
they're not having good news on the
economy you know the same day that the
president was signing or celebrating the
passage of the so-called inflation
reduction act inflation actually went up
um it is a tough set of numbers coming
out of August now gas prices are down
everybody's cheering for that that's
fantastic but the fact that all these
other things really the price of just
about everything else went up in August
the gas offset still didn't stop that
number from ticking up a little bit and
so we got to watch and see
um you know energy producers here in the
USA they still have their you know one
hand tied behind the back while their
Administration is yelling at them to
produce more and somehow crank up their
refineries
um to levels that would be very
beneficial we've got Putin in Europe and
that whole situation going on so we
gotta hope gas prices continue trending
downward because that ripples just like
the trains and that you know Supply
supply line issue would have rippled to
everything else
um gasoline certainly does that too but
there are plenty of economists out there
across the political spectrum and many
of them want to remain neutral who say
the underlying fundamentals here are not
good the fact that we still have all
these other core prices that are rising
inflation is still not under control
Shannon bream Fox News Sunday host not
going to be a stranger here on the Fox
News rundown podcast Shannon thanks
Kentucky you got it
foreign
[Music]
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as I take on American
Life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you download podcasts Raiden
review the Fox News rundown on Apple
podcasts or wherever you listen and now
some good news with Tanya J Powers
last weekend marked the 21st anniversary
of the terror Attacks of September 11
2001 and while that observation is a
somber one I witnessed something in
lower Manhattan I wanted to share with
you standing in the area with survivors
family members and First Responders one
thing caught my attention the dogs they
were walking through the crowd stopping
to receive pets and tummy rubs of which
there were a lot there were therapy dogs
and their handlers crisis counselors
Janice Campbell is the president and
founder of Tri-State canine response
team and told me that each year on
September 11 they bring teams to the
ceremony at Ground Zero we come out to
just really offer our services to
individuals and family members on these
types of days that it's really hard to
get through the all volunteer teams have
golden retrievers Labradors Bedlington
Terriers and more we don't really
differentiate as to what dog can really
be a crisis response talk it really is
on the temperament and the dogs have
special talents to be able to go through
the crowds of people and find who needs
them the most or you know whose bottom
lip is quivering or a tear coming down a
child's faces the dogs really are
empathetic in that way and kind of guide
us to who needs them the most so how do
they train the dogs to do that we really
can't train the dogs to that to do that
we train them for obedience getting
ready for unpredictable environments
working in large crowds but it's the
special things that the dogs have some
dogs have it more than others and it's a
true gift that we get to see that comes
back up the leash to us they've been to
three U.S cities that have had mass
shootings in just the past four months
and actually Logan this dog here he was
in Buffalo New York who vowed a Texas
and also in Highland Park Janice says
the dogs know when they've helped
someone they'll look back at us and say
you know I'd like to see this person and
then afterwards they look back like I
did a good job they can see their eyes
light up and they're really happy that
they were able to make that connection
and make a difference and they know the
work they're doing they really do in New
York City Tanya J Powers Fox News
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Janice Dean what's on your mind on
Sunday the 21st anniversary of the
September 11th Terror attacks I was
invited to attend a memorial reception
with George Pataki New York's 53rd
governor I was honored to be one of five
people chosen to receive his annual
Freedom award for the advocacy I've done
over the last several years on behalf of
the families whose loved ones died after
Contracting covid-19 in nursing homes
my husband Sean Newman a battalion chief
with the New York City Fire Department
came with me on a day that was already
filled with grief and sorrow for him on
9 11 he lost all 12 of the men in his
Firehouse who were working that day as
they ran into the World Trade Center
before they fell to the ground
and now over two years later he's still
mourning the loss of his parents who
both died from coronavirus during the
height of the pandemic in their separate
Elder Care Facilities but our gathering
in Midtown Manhattan with Governor
Pataki was uplifting and his foundation
has been committed to doing wonderful
work for New Yorkers
we were surrounded by people who had
lost loved ones but have been turning
their loss into something good by
bringing awareness to the meaning of
freedom in our country
as I was accepting the award on Sunday
afternoon I realized that there is a
link to what I've been fighting for
after the loss of my in-laws and the
attacks on our country September 11
2001.
it is the incredible Freedom we have
here in the United States
that freedom was assaulted 21 years ago
when the planes crashed into the
buildings in lower Manhattan taking the
lives of thousands of Americans with
them including 343 members of the FDNY
it was an attack on the American way of
life that so many have died for
including the men and women who went to
work that day and never came home
a part of our belief system as Americans
is about how much we cherish our freedom
unfortunately it must be constantly
defended
today I am thankful I live in a country
where those freedoms allow us to call
out Injustice where we see it even in
government
those rights gave me a voice to fight
against covid-19 policies in nursing
homes following the tragic deaths of
Mayan laws deaths that have revealed not
only poor governance but abject
corruption in New York state
freedom is hard freedom is messy but
anything less is oppression
we have a precious right as Americans
that we can never let go everyone has a
right to a voice that deserves to be
heard
and I am grateful to use my voice on
behalf of others that no longer have one
thank you Governor Pataki and your
foundation for celebrating democracy and
freedom on a day when we all needed to
hear something positive
and thank you for the incredible honor
of receiving such an important award and
recognition
don't forget your kindness and I'm
grateful to you for remembering the
lives we lost on 9 11 and the over 15
000 cherished Souls we lost in New York
nursing homes
janistine Fox News
listening to the Fox News rundown
Rundown
stay subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
precise personal powerful is America's
weather team in the palm of your hands
get Fox weather updates throughout your
busy day every day subscribe and listen
now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your podcasts
love Fox News click the Subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the Fox News rundown
playlist for the latest episodes